I think that people have an idea that
there is one kind of mind one kind of
mentality that is attracted to the
military and that's not necessarily true
it can be true I do understand it and
maybe in in this day and age it's more
true than certainly when my father went
into the war but my father was in three
wars and he was a massive lefty you know
he he was the most politically
open-minded liberal person and he used
to say no one hates war more than a
soldier you know he helped my brother
get conscientious objector status during
Vietnam he and and he would have helped
him get into the war if my if my brother
had felt that was what he was compelled
to do politically and ideologically so I
did not grow up in a conservative
household at all I grew up in a
household where there was a very strong
code about honor and about morality
which is a tricky word but it wasn't
honor that I necessarily equate with the
military itself I equate it with my
father and his spirit and who he was and
it would have been like that where he
would had he worked in a deli had he
been a lawyer that's just who he was and
and he was quite uncommon you know he
was open to everyone and he was a
feminist and he was you know of all of
my friends who were his my friends who
were gay if you were transgender if you
I had a friend who came to dinner one
night who brought his girlfriend who was
in the 80s there were these people who
they were called walkins and they were
they said they were their bodies had
been invaded by aliens so and my dad
just you know talked Terje was really
interested in her and not what did you
think about he said you know she was a
perfectly nice girl and what do I know
maybe she was you know it's just really
unless you were
really right-wing or he could sometimes
bristle at people who were maybe a
little - a little too forthcoming about
their their wealth you know people who
were very into talking about you know
what you know sports clubs and vacations
okay he didn't like to hear people
bragging about money and things like he
you know but I think that's kind of a
right-wing thing he always associated
that with and he wasn't into that so
there is a perception of the military
that's not entirely true I understand
where it comes from but it's not 100%
accurate
my father had retired from the military
when I was four but that's still you
know the residue of that remained it
lingered and and it hung in the air his
experience in the war you know and it
was something you know unnameable that
was very often came out in his behavior
in a really negative way in a very
frightening way in a very upsetting way
and I was always able to separate that
behavior from my father himself and I
don't think it's because I was an
exceptionally perceptive child I think
it's because my father the spirit of who
he was was so strong and so indomitable
that that shone through and I knew who
he was as a person and I knew there was
this other thing that that sort of would
come into the room that that was like a
fog that he was not in control of that
he was not proud of that it was almost
like he wasn't driving the car anymore
and I and I knew it's a rather
pedestrian way of saying but I knew it
wasn't his fault
do you know what I mean I knew that
wasn't him and and as he grew older and
mellowed and and those experiences
receded a little bit as other ones
became sort of more into the the what he
was do you know what I mean that that
sort of went away
somewhat and that other person was able
to resonate much more and I wasn't
necessarily afraid of that other thing
coming back so much and and that also is
a testament to his spirit and that he
was intelligent and and he was always
trying to better himself and always
reading and and he was an amazing
listener and and was so grateful he was
he really had gratitude some sort of art
form you know and generosity and and I
think those things over time rather than
him
McGrew him you know and I think over
time as as people tend to sometimes
their spirits diminish or they stop
looking and and moving past themselves
he just only his spirit only got larger
and it sort of eclipsed that that
difficult part that that hard part that
I grew up with that you know trails me
as well now as part of me and that that
can only be the result of a 19 year old
very sensitive boy going into the war at
a time when that was the honorable thing
to do that was not only not necessarily
expected fairly expected but it was the
honorable thing to do when people think
of war people think of movies people
think of games people think sometimes of
photographs people think sometimes of
stories but in general I think they
think of things which are one step
removed from what war actually is and if
you actually delve into that and you
think of the Korean War for example and
walking through you know thirty below
zero and there
are the ground is littered with men most
of whom under the age of 30 many of whom
under the age of 25 you know their
bodies blown to bits that have also been
stripped of their clothes so that other
people could use their clothes and their
frozen that's not the kind of thing
people think of in terms of reality they
think maybe it it brings up an image
they saw in a movie a game or something
but they don't think of it as reality
and in the 40s I think it was partly
because there was there wasn't a
widespread depiction of it in the media
do you know what I mean it was something
imagined which i think is always a
million times more potent the
imagination no one was facetiming from
the war no one was calling from the war
know you waited for letters you waited
for you know cryptic descriptions of
what was horrific and and you know
inferences which were you know like put
ice in your veins people don't have any
understanding of what war is I really
don't think the modern mind can take it
in and I don't think I think it's almost
been polluted too much to be able to I
think there needs to be some kind of
reaction I don't know what that is I
don't know if that's possible but I
think in order for it to stop people
have to understand what it is and I
think there's an acceptance of it
otherwise people is oh yeah there's
people at war those people in
Afghanistan if people don't really
understand what that means